[Music]  the publishers of Archie comics know if  you heard about this they announced that  they're killing off Archie yeah killing  off Archie  listen to this and they're doing it by  having Archie save his gay friend from  an assassin's bullet by jumping in the  path this is we're not making this up  this is true they're killing Archie and  it's very dramatic but I was thinking if  you're gonna kill off a beloved  character that is a really noble way to  go yeah you know what I mean saving your  friend is being persecuted by the way  the bullet very brave it's a lot more  inspirational than some of the other  ways they were planning on killing off  Archie  they tried there was a meth overdose  idea for a while there was deep vein  thrombosis from sitting on a plane seat  too long there was martyr to Hamas and  no one liked that idea  and the melis noble bathtub  slip-and-fall nobody thought  [Applause]  [Music]  you